[Musik]
[Gelächter]
hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt heute gibt es ein ganz
leckeres bisher eigentlich nur für uns
zwei gedacht weil mein mann ist nicht so
gerne mag wir machen heute
kaiserschmarren mein mann max hat weil
er keine süßen warme speisen mag aber
ich finde so dass es immer ganz lecker
und ich zeige euch jetzt einfach mal die
zutaten wir machen heute nämlich einen
ganz traditionellen kaisers machen und
dafür brauchen wir sechs eier die travel
wir auch gleich die habe ich zwei
esslöffel vanillezucker den hatte ich
selber gemacht wir brauchen eine prise
salz 250 gramm mehl dann brauchen wir
butter und zwar habe ich die bereits
geschmolzen
das sind 50 gramm hier habe ich 500
milliliter milch und ich habe hier ein
paar rosinen
das sind jetzt 100 gramm die kann man
vorher in rom oder zum beispiel in
apfelsaft einlegen falls kinder mit
essen und das sind die zutaten für den
teig und später kam er durch die
kaiserschmarren zum beispiel mit
apfelkompott essen oder mit pflaumenmus
aber das erzähle ich euch dann einfach
wir müssen jetzt zuerst mal die eier
trennen
das würde ich heute weil wir sie ihr
trennen müssen
und zwar gebe ich hier das nein warte
lass mich mal
sonst haben wir wieder schale und eigelb
drin
ich gebe es hier main rhein
und alle lassen sich am besten trennen
wenn sie noch kalt sind
da bleibt das eigelb noch schön zusammen
meines jetzt schon ein bisschen zimmer
waren besitzen ein bisschen hier draußen
stehen hatte
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich da eine prise salz zum 1
dazu damit die altersstruktur schneller
zerstört wird und wenn es dann steif ist
gebe ich noch ein bisschen zucker rein
[Musik]
und das eiweiß steif wenn ihr die
schüssel nehmt und einmal auf den kopf
stellen darf man nicht gelb und dann
warf allerdings dabei heraus fallen
jetzt die hälfte des zuckers dazu also
nur ein bisschen nicht alles ein
bisschen ruhig auch mal kurz ein und
kann ich jetzt kurz zur seite stellen
unternehmen direkt meinen job und gibt
da auch den zucker mit ihm das bild kurz
berührt
jetzt werden wir das mehl
hineingetrieben jetzt erstmal nur zum
triple
dann wird es nach kurths untergehoben
[Musik]
dann geben war für den mensch dazu
das hat sich das bisschen verbunden und
jetzt gebe ich einfach den rest dazu ich
machte mir stecken da jetzt gleich
wieder das handwerk gerät schneller
damit die restliche milch erstmal ein
bisschen darüber setzen ist so spritzt
kurz verrühren
und dann einfach den rest so
[Musik]
jetzt kommt dann noch die butter mit
rein
[Musik]
und jetzt werden wir hier noch unseren
eischnee einrühren und zwar einfach so
ein bisschen unterheben
dass wir das wie so dass ein schnee
heißt das auch so durch schnee
[Musik]
ich habe das jetzt einfach in zwei
portionen unter und der sorgt dafür dass
der kaiser machen gleich richtig flüssig
und locker ist
[Musik]
und es ist zwar dann nicht mehr ganz
traditionell aber ich gebe jetzt auch
noch ein bisschen abgeriebene
zitronenschale mit rein von der biozid
oder natürlich weil ich spüre dass das
richtig gut zu den teig passt
und einfach ein tolles aroma abgibt
ihr hattet ihr auch schon meine mutter
sie hier in der pfanne schmidt ich habe
jetzt da einen esslöffel rhein gegeben
[Musik]
das liegt schon richtig gut
jetzt starten
[Musik]
so ähnlich und jetzt werde ich die
pfanne etwas runter schalten auf etwa
mittlere stufe und füllten teil jetzt so
ein dass er ungefähr 1 zentimeter hoch
steht
[Musik]
und wer möchte kann jetzt noch die
rosinen dazu geben die kann man auch in
den teig anrühren
aber ich bin dann verteilen sie sich
einfach nicht so schön und hier hatte
nicht filmen
man könnte einfach mal drunter schauen
denn schon ein bisschen gebräunt ist ich
möchte es noch ein bisschen bräune
dann können wir es nämlich oben drin und
wenn euch dann die farbe unten gefällt
so wie es hier können wir das umdrehen
aber weil es jetzt so sehr unhandlich
ist und bittet das sowieso gleich heißen
werde ich das jetzt einmal vierter
und dann kann man das ganz leicht
eindringen
ich finde es ja auch aus der pfanne raus
machen aber das verbot weil das so ein
bisschen zu weich ist
jetzt einfach die seite auch noch ein
bisschen freundin lassen und dann können
wir gleich den kaiserschmarren
und wenn dieser kaiserschmarren die
richtige rolle hat können wir ihn auf
und bereiten das waren wir einfach mit
hilfe von zwei gabeln einfach irgend
mundgerechte stücke reißen
[Musik]
das heißt man einfache stücke und das
ist übrigens ein tiroler rezept was ich
hier habt und wieder sowieso unbedingt
mal nach österreich und dort mal eine
sachertorte essen und dann gibt es auch
ein konzept für eine sachertorte
[Musik]
und jetzt geben wir hier einfach ein
bisschen zucker drauf ich nehme ich
natürlich zimt zucker weil ich zum fan
bin und lassen das bisschen mit denen
pfanne karamellisieren
[Musik]
jetzt gebe ich das hier einfach auf
einen servierteller und ich stellte
immer mal wieder war damit die
kaiserschmarren nicht kalt werden
jetzt habe ich die letzte portion
insgesamt waren es jetzt bei mir dran
und voll
und wenn ich die ausgebacken haft zeige
ich euch das endergebnis
wir haben jetzt alle drei fanden
kaiserschmarrn fertig gemacht und ich
werde jetzt noch anrichten puderzucker
brauchen wir auch gleich und habe jetzt
eine portion ohne rosinen gemacht und
zwei personen mitnehmen
habe
kann ich das mal darüber heute nicht so
schnell müde und jetzt darüber und jetzt
hier ein bisschen drehen sie sind
puderzucker noch drüber die sehen ja
nicht sooo süß weil wir nur zwei
esslöffel zucker im teig haben das
reicht schon
ich mache
und wir servieren das jetzt mit etwas
apfelmus den habe ich vorhin kurz selber
gekocht einfach zwei äpfel mit bisschen
zu kommen zitronensaft auf dem herd und
stehen geben
aber man kann das auch mit ganz anderen
dingen anrichten
traditionell wird zum beispiel mit
blumenmuster wird oder ich finde auch
dass so ein warmer kaiserschmarrn zu
einem kalten oder eben ganz andere dinge
vielleicht habt ihr ja noch ein paar
ideen und könnt uns da einfach schreiben
wir werden selbst im kaiserschmarren
schmecken lassen probiert haben wir
schon
er schmeckt richtig schön fluffig wäre
vielleicht ein bisschen probleme mit dem
schnee hat kann gern noch eine prise
back coolen farben geben
aber bei uns hat es super geklappt und
sie sind und sehr gut bildungen das
rezept gibt es zum nachlesen auffällig -
blog.de und wir freuen uns schon aufs
nächste mal dann tschüss
[Musik]